all right let's let's get to the first
of two conversations we're gonna first
talk to
uh stephen kenneth destiny benell the
second we are gonna try to clear the air
okay guys let's see if we can do that
i'm gonna try calling him right now
and see what we've got going on
um
guys i think this is working
steven
hello how are you
i'm doing great david deepak
pac-man how are you doing let me
introduce to my audience if you're not
familiar with them we're going to be
speaking with the most prominent
cuban american
streamer of our time stephen
kenneth
destiny
bonnell ii welcome back stephen
thanks for having me back on what's up
oh i think your discord might be using
or the incorrect microphone or it sounds
like a webcam microphone
yeah i think that is where you mean what
you're hearing me through
yeah yeah let me see if i can change
look i'm going to try changing something
standby
yeah if you click user settings and go
to um oh no i know it sometimes just
comes through muffled is that better oh
yeah now you're good to go okay good
good good and my audience can still hear
me everybody can hear me still
uh oh no my audience can no longer hear
me
oh my audience can hear me okay and you
can still hear me right stephen yep loud
and clear beautiful
well listen i think that there's a lot
of clearing the air here that needs to
be done
okay now i do want to say first and
foremost that
since our last conversation
i have received uh dozens and dozens of
emails tweets
links to various um
reddit threads and
i am not going to be sort of like
addressing anything in particular in the
sense that every sentiment was expressed
ranging from
never waste your time with destiny again
and
destiny should never waste his time with
you again like the full gamut was the
reaction of stuff from people the whole
spectrum exactly exactly all right
so i mean i think listen
i think tempers have sort of cooled off
a little bit since the other day is that
fair to say
well i don't think i had a big temper at
all but sure
yeah what about it
well let's not even get into that uh and
and so
let's not get into an argument as to
whether tempers flared let's skip that
argument you don't want to get into a
meta argument about the arguments let's
see if we can avoid a three layers
removed argument at this point in time
um
i think that uh
a lot of things were said
okay and
it's i i was not expecting that it would
become a sort of point counterpoint
thing i don't know if you were expecting
it
uh i don't you know i go into every
conversation with no expectations and
then every conversation is just an
absolute joy because i never know what
to expect oh okay all right so like i
mean in all seriousness
you felt good about the conversation
well no i thought it was a horrible
conversation oh okay of course all right
okay good so we're it sounds like we're
both on the same page about that that's
good no i mean i would i would expect it
to be for us to both feel away yeah it
would be easy i think to just to just
explain away that the conversation was a
disaster by each of us saying it was a
disaster merely because the other person
said xyz which i don't agree with which
i feel like would get us into the exact
same circle
probably yeah yeah so maybe
like
i'm sort of happy to say
um
man what am i even happy to say i don't
know that i'm happy to say anything i'm
trying to
not a single thing to be grateful for on
the day after thanksgiving yeah not one
thing to be happy about i think that um
i mean i guess okay let me let me do one
thing where i can let me let me at least
clarify one thing one thing that people
did write to me which i ended up feeling
bad about because of how it was
perceived was when i asked if you were
mildly autistic at the end of the
conversation there were two reactions
that made me feel really bad one was
that people said
i was i was used i was using that as an
insult but i would never i mean it's
like saying
i'm i'm insulting people for being
diabetic i'm not gonna you know
there's no i'm not there's no laughing
at medical conditions for me it was not
meant as an insult it was not meant like
anything like that so if it came out i
first of all i don't do apologies i
don't care okay uh but
diabetic isn't the same thing right
well it's stigmatized that's the whole
point i mean that's right it's seen
totally differently but for me it's like
i wouldn't laugh at any medical
condition
sure but the the i think the issue with
bringing up the autistic thing is it
appears that you're trying to undermine
everything that was previously said
by pointing to so it would be the
equivalent of me asking at the end like
david do you have a learning disability
like it would be like that type of thing
and then my goal is to impeach your
character based upon the answers you
give to that line of questions fair
right fair and so to the extent that
that's how it came off that is that was
not my intention and it was
it may have been an inappropriately
timed question i will i will stipulate
to that but it was not a joke of any
kind and for me autism is not funny
god okay is that fair
yeah if you feel that yeah i can i'm not
here to tell you how you can feel about
things so sure okay all right good um
what else yeah i mean i don't know in
terms of other stuff you know i guess i
was in one sense i was a little bit
surprised and i don't know if it was
surprised in from the standpoint of
positive or the standpoint of negative
that in the aftermath
i've people were linking me to
quite literally multi-page almost
line-by-line analyses of the
conversation we had
which i don't know if it's like wow
people care enough about what was said
that they took that much time to do it
or maybe some people are a little too
wrapped up in the in our in our
conversation which at the end of the day
is
i don't know i don't know how meaningful
our conversation should be to just the
people at large you know
well i mean i would hope that my
conversations with people are pretty
meaningful because that's the whole
reason i do what i do is so that my
words have meaning to the people that
are listening right i think that's a
it's pretty fair to expect that people
are going to try to find meaning in the
conversations we have with others now
as a public figure yeah that seems fair
that seems fair so you were not
surprised at the amount of like analysis
that was done
no i don't think so okay fair fair
um
all right and i mean listen at the end
of the day now with the hindsight of the
verdict the verdict was
basically as expected i mean i thought
that it was conceivable that there would
be
some guilties on them on the minor
charges but two of the minor charges
didn't even make it to the jury
uh so i think you and i both agree that
there was nothing surprising about the
verdict is that fair
yeah but i mean the verdict was never
really the that's the boring part right
well i don't know about that i mean i
think that if the verdict is different
it would be number one surprising
i don't know that written house gets the
hero welcome from
trump and tucker and everybody if the
verdict is different i mean i do think
the verdict is
meaningful um i feel like the verdict is
meaningless because i think it's more
interesting that the interesting
conversation was how the verdict was
arrived at it's kind of like saying um
to use a charged example you know black
people tend to commit more crime in the
united states than white people like
that fact isn't interesting the
interesting discussion is well why is
that the case right some people on the
very far right will say culture or very
far right will say genetics people on
the left will say socioeconomic factors
environmental conditions so like that
that argument is the more interesting
part not necessarily that factoid so
when we talk about like the verdict of
the case in my opinion at least um you
know whether or not he's innocent or
guilty isn't the interesting part the uh
the conversations are more like if he
was black would he have made it to trial
would the cops have killed him was the
judge being fair like was the
prosecution being earnest um you know
could a another person afford that
defense like i think these are the more
interesting questions rather than just
saying like oh well here's the verdict i
think in my opinion do you feel like you
got interesting answers to the more
interesting questions
well that's where all of my discussion
has been to yeah i've always told people
that you should never be too invested in
the verdict of a jury case i mean we can
hope for things but i mean jury cases
can go anyway right
either direction we have no idea
fair all right so in terms of your
coverage arc are you moving on from that
case or are you going to continue doing
content related to it
um i've i hope to move on it already
like has dominated so much of like the
past like two weeks i think of what i've
done because everybody's talking about
it but i mean on to the next thing right
what's your reaction to um
the hero's welcome by trump and stuff
like that
i mean it's pretty cringe but it's to be
expected um i mean especially when
people on the left like are pushing so
hard in the other direction i mean it's
more or less what i would expect if one
group of people is going to [ __ ] on
somebody then they're probably going to
be welcomed by the other group of people
uh that's interesting so you believe
he's been lionized by the right because
he's been attacked by the left
i think that that plays into it now
it probably would have happened to some
extent anyway but i mean if enough
people are going to make somebody out to
be a villain you can find a group of
people that'll make that same person not
to be a hero i gotcha i think that both
both ends definitely play into that what
was your thought on the arbory verdict
uh i didn't i didn't follow that trial
so i'm really hesitant to say anything
on it but i don't think anything was
ever presented that would have made me
think that that should have gone any
anyway differently i don't believe that
any of those three guys witnessed
directly that person committing a crime
um so i don't know if they had the right
to to chase him down and and confront
him to do their citizens arrest or
whatever
i don't think that three grown men it
didn't seem like he had a weapon or
anything at the time right so there was
no reason their life was in danger so i
don't know why like a gun would have
been brought out um
everything for how those verdicts played
out seemed to me like they probably
should have been that way but i say that
cautiously because i didn't follow that
trial or look at all the evidence for
that but these are just like the things
that i've read the snippets and
everything i've read why why that one of
the first things you said is interesting
why were you
much so much more interested in the
written house trial than rather than
this one
um because i thought that this trial was
like pretty it felt to me and again i'm
very cautiously saying this guy i didn't
watch but it felt to me like this one
was pretty obvious the whole time you
had like um there were three dudes in a
truck they saw a black guy jogging they
thought he was a [ __ ] criminal and
then they chased him down and they
essentially ended up executing him in
the street with a shotgun that's that
seems insane to me it seems really bad i
don't think i could be wrong but i don't
think anybody was defending the three
white guys i don't think any maybe there
were a few crazies on the internet but
for the most part it seemed like that
they were like universally panned as
like the bad guys oh that's interesting
in other words you thought that
the verdict was so much more obvious in
this one that it was less interesting to
you
yeah i think so yeah the only thing i
saw was like tim poole quibbling over
like what a citizen's arrest was but
otherwise
it seemed like nobody was gonna go out
to defend those guys hey by the way
speaking of tim poole did you see this
recent video where he was with um alex
jones in studio
um
probably not i saw one where it was like
tim paul alex jones and a bunch of
people joe rogan and stuff and some in a
trailer yeah no no no not that one i
mean the one where he was like in alex
jones studio he somehow manages to
crowbar into the first two minutes three
times that he has a girlfriend which is
so funny because i don't know if you saw
that video like a year ago that had a
very in-cell feel where he was saying
like i'm single and it's like clearly
every it clearly it's not me so it's
clearly everybody else
oh gotcha okay i thought you were gonna
refer to the there was some video where
i think he talks about how he can go on
tinder for like two minutes and like
pick up any girly ones and blah blah
blah was like okay oh no i never i
didn't see that one i didn't see that
one yeah no it's it's worth seeing it's
very interesting he seems almost like
smitten with alex jones it's very
interesting
okay the other funny thing is alex jones
seems to continue referring to him as a
leftist even on the thing like here's a
leftist i'm willing to have on
wait who oh he refers to tim poole as a
leftist yeah although then he hedges by
going you're not even necessarily on the
left you're just sort of like a normal
pro-freedom american or something like
it's it's like very very weird the whole
thing is weird and the i also don't know
if you've noticed but like when alex
jones has a guest on and you see alex
jones in the reaction shot he seems very
bored with what his guests are saying
like he doesn't really seem to even pay
attention
yeah i mean that he's
he's a character um i feel like there's
this whole group of people that
it became like a trend to not call
yourself a conservative even though you
were a conservative in everything but
name only like i i don't know if i would
say dave rubin started that but he said
he kept the
last real liberal thing for a while yeah
or why i left the left but i'm not
really a conservative but that you are
in every single way i don't yeah i don't
know why yeah yeah yeah no it's crazy
uh well listen i uh
i i don't want to make this an if poligy
day but to the extent that i did
anything wrong notice i'm not saying to
the extent that i offended anyone to the
extent that i did anything wrong
i do apologize to you and your audience
for the other day
yeah you're let's listen we don't care
about apologies here david all we care
about is the love we have for each other
and nothing is going to overcome that
okay my fellow gusano in arms all right
oh god um now let me check in with you
one oh here's also one thing i wanted to
mention
you know i used to be banned on twitch
i'm not anymore so we're all in the
clear but right now we're observing your
stream with uh i'm logged out and
there's a really interesting thing i'm
looking at in the bottom left which says
destiny viewers also watch
john
jerka
david pakman and something called chud
logic what are john jerka and chud logic
john is uh just i
can't really put in that's kind of like
asking like what does acid feel like i
can't really put into words that stream
you just have to experience that for
yourself and then chad logic is a uh
british i think he does like kind of
like political commentary stuff and are
they on the left or the right
john circa uh defies political spectrum
analysis and child logic is probably
like left i'd say
and then the other two that it says are
like your viewers also watch in addition
to my show is echo rules and xander hall
do those ring a bell
aika rules i i don't want to say
anything mean about her because she's
really nice people she seems a little
insane left person um xander hall is
i i don't know
he he's a political person he seems
okayish okay all right all right very
good yeah uh well listen um
i'm glad to be able to clear the air
with you and i'll pay pal you the money
i agreed on a little bit
later okay and are you is it looking
like you're going to be in l.a in the
second half of december or what's it
looking like
uh well my lease is officially up on the
20th so it'll depend on when you're here
but i don't even know if i'll be here
we'll see oh my god i get in i think on
the 19th
oh wow i'm almost for sure not gonna be
here then and and you're gonna be in oh
no no i get in the 17th i get in the
17th
okay just highly unlikely then and when
you think you'll be where are you saying
where you will be here i feel like i'll
be gone in the first week of december
but we'll see you know and and you're
heading down down south
uh
am i is my oh yeah of course yes i get
yeah miami i guess okay feels weird to
say i live in l.a and i'm going down
south but i guess sure and are you
saying whether you're doing like
miami proper or miami beach
um you know i was gonna do miami beach
uh you know there's not a lot of units
available to get anywhere and stuff so
did you say there aren't unix available
units available oh you oh like an
apartment unit oh my god i was like what
did you do what exactly are you doing
down there yeah yeah there's an
abundance of unix like that wouldn't
even make sense of course that wouldn't
make sense um yeah but it's um i don't i
think it's miami proper but i don't know
um yeah but yeah and is molina coming
with us or
um i would hope so unless she hasn't
told me something
she's gonna tie to me now because she's
on a k1 so if she leaves me she's kicked
out of the country forever so she's
she's a slave wait you guys you guys are
married
well yeah that's what the whole process
has been moving towards yeah oh i didn't
realize that i know so you've been
you've you're legally married at this
time well not legally married she's here
right now in k1 we have like 60 days to
fill up the paperwork you get married oh
okay okay okay
yeah i you know what would be really
great if uh you know how sometimes you
have to go to these meetings where they
like want to make sure you're really a
couple and stuff like that
you've heard of this like immigration
officials yeah we've already done this
oh yeah it would be great if there's
another meeting
if you bring a screenshot of when you
guys were in copenhagen streaming and
there's like a table of people behind
you and they're furiously staring at you
it would be great if you presented that
as the evidence that you're really
together to immigration officials i
would love that
wait i totally
don't understand
i don't remember when you were in
coaching oh god never mind no no i
understand now holy yikes that was the
most cringe moment i've ever streamed in
my entire life oh my god
oh my god yeah i know what you're
talking about that's an historic moment
in streaming that's a historic moment
for me that's when i committed to twitch
after that i was like i need to be on
this platform jesus that um apparently
the interview is really easy or melina
said it was like they didn't like every
time i read on the internet they're like
oh they might ask you crazy things like
you know like what is the favorite
flavor of coffee creamer that this
purple but apparently they asked like
three or four questions like oh you guys
love each other you chill like oh cool
and then i was like whatever so did you
have to bring documents that you guys
are like together for real
yeah but i don't even know how much they
mattered but we had like it was like a
50 page [ __ ] thing of like our
screenshots of our instagram history
like photos where we've traveled an
airplane it's a whole bunch of [ __ ] do
you like a foreign wife or
do i no no i'm foreign i'm the foreign
one
did you have to do this process no no no
no i uh i just signed up for a passport
when i was 17 and that i got citizenship
that way because my parents were already
citizens at the time oh gosh you gotcha
okay it's a whole different process
all right well steven listen i'll check
with you i'll ask one more question i'm
curious because i just got home
literally four hours ago when i'm
streaming now um is this uh is this new
variant the new variant is it anything
to be concerned about you mean omicron
oh is it omicron i thought they were
going with new i guess they're going
with omicron
okay man that's just a really scary name
i know i know the name doesn't bode well
here's my take on it from looking at you
know what everybody's all various
experts have been saying it's called a
variant of concern because we should be
concerned but it's not a variant of
panic we don't yet we won't know for two
weeks if it actually evades vaccines and
at this time there's no evidence it's
more deadly it's like you just gotta
wait you know okay sure i don't know if
i read this or if i'm making this
overhead but i thought i saw a headline
that said that the united states is
looking to ban all travel from african
countries soon in a week i haven't seen
that
okay i'll look for maybe south africa
but i don't know
uh-huh no okay oh it was just south
africa you're right the united states
will shoot for from non-us citizens from
south africa and seven oh and seven
other countries starting one day so
maybe some other afghanistan that's
probably it that sounds right yeah i
mean listen we just got to see what's
going on did you get a third dose
uh i'm scheduled to i think in two days
oh okay and what do you know what you're
getting
uh i think i sign up for the madonna one
because i think it's more yeah
it's sort of like a uh
you know like the ga the prisoner's
dilemma and game theory where it's like
no matter what you think the other
person's going to do here's what you
should do
with the vaccines it's like no matter
what your first vaccine was
you should get the the modern booster
that's like it's the same thing yeah oh
yeah i'm gonna say that i think that i
think the moderna and the pfizer shots
are the same it's just that the modern
one was like three times the dose so i
think that's why the uh um data is
panned out better for it yeah i don't
know but i know it's more i don't know
about three times but yeah i think it's
three times because the modern booster
is half the dose of the original shot
but i think it's still more than the
pfizer one right right but yeah yeah
okay
all right very good well listen it's
good to check in i'll be in touch and uh
you know with peace and love to the dgg
community and uh please stop posting
about me in destiny's subreddit okay
okay i love everybody all right talk to
you soon thanks love you bye
all right folks there is stephen
kenneth
destiny
bennell ii great to check in with him
and to clear the air